good day be home by dinner I love you
Mr Fielding good morning Catherine
and here are your daughters Angela and
Catherine about seven hours ago and
that's the last information we have
Catherine Angela if you can hear this we
love you please come home
Angela can you tell your dad how long
you were gone a few hours
baby you've been gone three days
what'd you say I didn't say nothing I
thought I heard you say something hey
baby you okay
wherever those girls went they brought
something back with them the body and
the blood of Jesus Christ
what Catherine body in the blood
the body in the blood
the body and the blood Catherine
[Applause]
have you ever seen anything like this
on me no but there are people out there
who have
[Music]
[Applause]
you have some experience with a
possession yes more than that like
I'll get our girls back
scared
who did you do
[Music]
is that Catherine's heartbeat they're
beating in sync
[Music]
[Applause]